chris ballard with us the colts general
manager you know one of the big story
lines last year is andrew luck healthy
how do we know that the shoulders
finally healed there was so much
misinformation from the year before and
i respect you for owning it answering
the questions understanding that people
were going to be skeptical that the
colts were going to have to prove it
luck was going to have to prove it and
prove it he did in a tremendous way last
season so congratulations on how that
went it's got to feel good this year to
not have those questions lingering
around no there's no doubt to be able to
go in the season knowing that you know
andrew's healthy
is going to get his first real off
season to really work really in the last
probably three where he can really just
work on being a better quarterback right
and it's not in rehab mode
there's no question that year will build
some character um in terms of being you
know forthright and honest and you know
this is where we're at and i think it
strengthens us you know not only the
bond between
me and andrew but andrew in the
organization right
in all honesty i mean because i know you
did you you confronted all the questions
last year was there a moment though
where you were like uh oh i don't know
if he's gonna be able to play early on
in the season you you truly knew he
could do it all year yeah i mean
i guess i
i just had seen the process play out
and i just had a a really strong belief
in him
and
the way he was working
the people he was working with i had a
strong conviction of where he was going
i knew it was going to take time i mean
that
you know
everybody expected him to you know step
in week one
and be a you know be a pro bowl
quarterback and i just think when you
haven't played in a year
it takes you need live bullets i mean
you need you can practice rep all you
want but you've got to get into live
bullet situations
and then he has to build confidence
again
and i thought just every game you'd see
little little signs of it um and then
and then it just took off so it's pretty
cool to watch yeah last year i remember
you telling us that you believed the
colts were two drafts away from becoming
a contending team and you were one draft
off how do you follow that up this year
now that there are heightened
expectations with the team no and and
i've talked a lot about this you know
we're no no matter what the outside
world thinks we'll just we'll continue
to settlement
that we've set the bar really high we do
that to ourselves anyways and you know
we're going to create expectations that
every year we've got to be able to
produce in the draft you just i just
think it's the lifeblood of an
organization
um we have a very strict criteria of
what we're looking for um the character
of the player
uh it matters it absolutely matters and
we'll continue down that road i thought
it was one of the great things our
scouts did last year and they did a they
did a tremendous job digging into
the type of people
we were bringing into the building um
yes they had talent but on the flip side
they also had very strong
football character right i mean they
they had a will to be great um and
that's one of the really
neat things that you see i mean between
quentin
leonard braden
lewis
all of those kids you know they're very
high character and they're all driven to
be the best they can be yeah i mean
darius leonard talk about him i mean
south carolina state did you expect him
to just explode onto the scene the way
he did well i'd be lying if i sit here
and
could sit here and tell you that i
thought the guy was going to be
first-team all-pro as a rookie coming
from south carolina state yeah um but we
liked him i mean we
our scout you know jamie moore had a
very strong conviction
on on darius and as we started going
down the process through the senior bowl
through interviewing through meeting him
uh we knew he had a chance to he was a
great fit for our scheme at the will
linebacker position right and we thought
he could ascend in time did we think in
year one he would do what he what he did
no but as
i'll never forget sitting at the
washington game i'm sitting next to matt
and matt shoved the piece of paper in
front of me it said 19 tackles two force
fumbles i said my lord i think from that
moment on i said wow we we got something
really special here you talked about
character of football players you're
here at the scouting combine what is to
you the number one indicator of
character as you're trying to to weed
out these 336 players to find the guys
you're going to draft well it's a and
it's hard
especially in today's day and age where
kids from a very young age
are getting recruited
offered scholarships told them the best
thing since sliced bread we live in a
highlight
you know a highlight world where their
highlight tape really matters i think
the number one
there's got to be a sense of humility
to where they want to get better
they they can take coaching they can
take criticism and they want to get
better that's that's you know you tell
you'll sit in a room with a kid
and you'll you'll show him things that
he's doing wrong and how he reacts to it
you know does he react defensively or
does he say you know what those are
things that i need to i need to really
improve on right uh one of the big free
agents that are out there a lot of
people kind of put a le'veon bell do you
guys do you envision being in that
sweepstake
you understand he can't talk about
players that are still under contract
with other teams yes you're right chris
that's just loaded a shot
[Laughter]
damn i feel stupid now chris yeah it
would be okay if we hadn't had that
conversation but we've had that
conversation story i didn't think it was
like antonio brown
not until march 13th
all right we gotta hey we gotta go chris
thanks for your time
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports